welcome back to cbs this morning
in what's being viewed as a watershed
moment for the trans community
the oscar-nominated star of the movie
juno has come out as transgender
in a powerful social media post elliott
page formerly known as ellen page
wrote my joy is real but it is also
fragile
the truth is despite feeling profoundly
happy right now and knowing
how much privilege i carry i am also
scared
vladimir duty is here with more on
paige's heartfelt message vlad good
morning
good morning page also came out as
non-binary
a gender identity that's neither man nor
woman so
page uses the pronouns they them
as well as he paige's courageous message
is resonating with trans
and non-trans people alike
in coming out as transgender the
umbrella academy star elliot page writes
i can't begin to express how remarkable
it feels to finally love who i
am enough to pursue my authentic self i
think i'm in love with you
age's career has spanned more than two
decades including
juno and the hit inception what happens
when you start messing with the physics
of it all
page came out as gay in 2014 and has
been married to emma porter for nearly
three years
in his post he shared his fears i'm
scared of the invasiveness
the hate and of violence the
discrimination
towards trans people is rife insidious
and cruel
resulting in horrific consequences
according to the human rights campaign
at least 40 transgender or gender
non-conforming people have been killed
this year alone
most of them black and latinx
transgender women
nick adams is with the gay and lesbian
alliance against defamation while we see
growing acceptance we also see growing
backlash particularly
during the last four years of this
administration celebrities are showing
their support
anna kendrick wrote elliot page's words
here are so beautiful
and so eloquent while miley cyrus simply
posted
elliott rules page told others like him
who deal with harassment self-loathing
abuse
i see you i love you and i will do
everything i can to change this world
for the better
nick adams told me how powerful paige is
coming out is he's someone so many
people feel
they know and love and that helps change
perceptions
and gives other transgender people the
strength to live their truth as well
yes i say bravo bravo at elliott page
there's something when someone admits
that i'm afraid
yes when you're doing something that's
very brave and very personal
that i think is very empowering it's
going to change lives and help a lot of
people i think that's
yeah and i think i think for younger for
younger viewers this is almost a
shoulder shout out it's congratulations
good courageous and everything but it's
like you know this is part of their life
if you're an older person in this
country this wasn't part of your youth
it may not have been part of your
vocabulary you're a little confused by
it
we can't get to all of it here i would
encourage people to go to glaad
read about it a little bit talk about it
with people and and
and and this is this is this is the new
world you know there will be some that
don't understand it but they need to
exactly they certainly need to try and i
mean
it was interesting what nick adams said
there's growing acceptance but there is
also growing backlash because this is
confusing a lot of people and uh but but
it's but it's happening but elliot page
is going to make a difference and people
will pay attention
yeah we'll all be educated always made a
very bad decision
all right vlad thank you very much